what's going on guys this is rob and
let's do exactly what we said we were
going to do which is to make a spoiler
review of spider-man no way home uh this
movie was amazing which
this video is going to have spoilers
the title and the thumbnail literally
tell you that so if you get mad about it
having spoilers well that's your fault
so here's the thing
i loved it man it was it was it was
phenomenal it was the best spider-man
movie today and here's the funny thing
about this i love that like when you
look at like like toby maguire's
spider-man or you look at andrew
garfield spider-man they basically had
an origin story that was just one movie
long
what they basically did with the end of
this film is turn the entire trilogy
into an origin story the whole thing is
basically just one big origin story
which is cool imagine like spiderman one
with tobey maguire spread over three
movies and that's basically what this is
it was phenomenal so uh let's talk about
the big cameo for a second right like
the the the big cameo from the movie
charlie cox this was amazing i loved
sitting in the in the audience and like
it was kind of funny because it like it
was it was like the worst timing ever
right because if you're watching the
movie mariah had like a question or a
comment or something that she turns to
me and then i was like no no no watch
this and then like you get to the scene
when like they're back home and they're
talking to the lawyer and you see the
hand with the cane and then like as soon
as that popped up somebody was like oh
my god and then like then like charlie
cox sits down and people are just like
yes like people were so happy about it
so it was really cool be on the lookout
for fan reactions across youtube to
charlie cox showing up in the uh in the
spider-man no way home film it was cool
to see him i love the idea of seeing
charlie cox here i love the scene when
like he's kind of explaining everything
that's going on and he's telling peter
parker and his family like you guys are
cool uh happy you're gonna need a really
good lawyer because
yeah like like you're gonna need a
really good lawyer man and so you get
that moment because like everybody knows
where peter parker lives now because his
identity is out there so obviously his
address and all that kind of stuff
leaked online and so somebody throws a
brick through the window and like
charlie cox catches it like that right
he catches it in his hand and peter's
like what he's like he's like how did
you do that he's like i'm just a really
good lawyer but like obviously you know
it's because he's daredevil and so it's
just like oh i loved i loved that scene
so much i absolutely adored it uh having
said that let's talk about the villains
for a second i loved how they handled
the villains i wish they'd done a little
bit more with some of the villains right
so dr octopus of course is the first one
we get that scene on the bridge it's the
first thing that happens right basically
end up having the spell go awry with
doctor strange and peter parker you
don't quite know the motivation or what
happened with the spell going awry that
led to those villains showing up by the
time doctor octopus appears but it's
cool to see the fight between the two
because tom holland has no idea what's
going on and dr octopus doesn't know
it's not tobey mcguire in fact looking
at his suit he was just like wow man
like you think a new suit's really gonna
make any difference and the fight goes
on for a little while and it's cool
because tom holland doesn't really know
how to counter dr octopus he knows how
to like bob and weave and dodge the
tentacles but he doesn't really know how
to overcome them in the same way that
toby maguire does so that lack of
experience facing off against otto shows
but it doesn't make peter parker look
incompetent it just makes him look
unfamiliar with dr octopus and that
makes sense because it'd be kind of
foolish to believe that peter parker
would know exactly how to counter every
villain he meets the first time he meets
them there's a learning curve there so i
absolutely loved that what was really
really awesome and i thought what was
hilarious was when dr octopus stole the
centerpiece from peter parker's suit and
then incorporated it into his tentacles
and he's like wow nanotech you've really
outdone yourself and then when he goes
to kill peter peter brings the face of
his suit down to his chest and that's
what actually keeps doctor octopus from
impaling him with his tentacle and
that's when otto realizes it's not toby
mcguire spider-man and he's like you're
not peter but because of the fact that
he stole part of peter's suit peter's
able to hijack his tentacles and i love
that right it's literally like a
bluetooth connection it's just like like
what is it like new nude item or
something like that detected and then
it's like interfacing and then like
literally peter parker just steals he
takes over the tentacles of dr octopus
he's like moving him with his hand like
opening and closing him with his hand
it's cool it's an amazing moment it's
absolutely hilarious i love that but
that bike of course came to a close
pretty quick and that's when the green
goblin shows up right now here's the
other thing too i love the way they
handled peter parker's spider sense i
don't recall exactly how it was handled
in spider-man far from home i know that
in spider-man no way home it was
virtually non-existent it was kind of
there that he was sort of learning about
the fact that it was there i think our
first real indication of peter parker's
spider sense came in like infinity war
right like when the hair raises up on
his arm and that kind of thing but this
looks like the most developed version of
his spider sense at the very least it
it's kind of activated in such a way to
where even if he doesn't know exactly
how it works he knows enough to know
that something's wrong so it's kind of
just like a ringing in his ears that
seems to indicate that like something's
about to happen and it's an amazing
moment right like when green goblin
shows up like the pumpkin bomb gets
thrown it's like the hahaha you know
like you see him like come from like the
smoke and then they get teleported away
to doctor strange i love the the
explanation that doctor strange gave um
again this is one of those instances
where like the mcu strikes again right
the explanation is so much simpler than
we were initially led to believe that
it's basically instead of everybody who
knows peter parker is spider-man
forgetting about that it pulled in
people who knew that peter parker was
spider-man it's a really cool concept
because i i just i love this idea that
with it being that simple it makes it
easy to grasp at the same time the you
know what you would expect in the
aftermath of that is that if everyone
across the multiverse knows that peter
parker is spider-man and they were
yanked into the universe then that would
basically mean that earth would just
fill up with people and the explanation
doctor strange gives is he was able to
close off the spell before it got to
that point and so basically the villains
that you see in the movie are
essentially the ones who managed to kind
of sneak through right it kind of fell
through the cracks and ended up in the
universe that's cool right the lizard's
already been captured doctor octopus is
thrown in there and then at that point
it's up to peter and and mj and ned
leeds and all them they got to go
forward and do their thing having said
that you're not really given any
explanation in terms of why jamie foxx
looks the way he does now as opposed to
the way he does in in the sony films i
mean i would surmise that it's probably
kind of a little little subtle thing
where the mcu is like everything's
better here and so like he looks better
right that's kind of a cool thing um any
theories that existed out there that
threw out the idea that um that jamie
foxx or any of those guys gets their get
their hands on like stark tech or
anything like that it's true but it's
not true so like the the rumor that we
had talked about where you had like the
power broker who was involved of course
that's not the case instead what peter
has in his possession in this really
unhappy hogan's apartment because that's
where they're staying was basically just
a synthesizer it's just a device that
literally brings to life anything that
they could possibly imagine and and
what's really cool about this is a fight
does break out between peter and doctor
strange but the fight itself is really
more based on the idea that doctor
strange is like they're all destined to
die in their universes right like
they're supposed to die there right dr
octopus is supposed to die in spider-man
2 green goblin's supposed to die and
spider-man 1. jamie foxx is supposed to
die in amazing spider-man 2 the lizard's
supposed to die and all these characters
they're all supposed to basically be
killed by their spider-man or really by
circumstances in their own respective
universes i.e the way those movies ended
but with peter parker it's just like no
no you know tom holland's like they
don't have to die we can fix them right
like we can cure them it's not really
one of those things where it's like we
can rehabilitate them and get them to
see the error of their ways and their
hearts will grow three sizes bigger than
they were before it's like no no we can
cure electro and we can cure kurt
connors and we can cure the green goblin
and dr octopus we can cure all these
guys and they actually do for the most
part right the first one is dr octopus
which is awesome because then he becomes
a good guy and basically starts working
alongside peter and mj and all those
folks after that it's like this amazing
statement made by the green goblin when
like they're all in the apartment which
by the way having the green goblin and
electro and sandman and dr octopus and
like like all these guys all in the same
like apartment basically like with each
other hanging out what's cool i loved
that i loved that whole scene like i
loved that moment and it's actually
green goblin that gets electro and those
guys to abandon the idea of being fixed
and to go forward and do their own thing
so that's where electro actually steals
an arc reactor and then takes off right
so he ends up going and doing his own
thing because arc reactors as you guys
know are just a limitless source of
energy which amplifies his power and
makes him stronger now of course you get
the kind of fight scenes and things like
that right some skirmishes and so on and
so forth and there's some cool stuff
right it's pretty interesting the way it
unfolds the movie i would say in the
middle is a lot of dialogue it was never
born right there were never any points
where i was bored in the movie it was
phenomenal if you're coming out of
something like um like eternals and
you're afraid the movie's gonna feel
like eternals no it's it's amazing it's
a it's a great movie but let's let's
let's talk about that let's talk about
the big thing the thing that everybody
wants to know right are andrew garfield
and toby maguire
in this movie
no they're not in this movie um
just messing around they are and it's
amazing when they show up oh my god it's
so cool so it's actually ned leeds that
gets them into the movie and it's one of
the weird things ned leeds can use magic
now we're not really given an
explanation why but he can basically use
the the sling ring thing that doctor
strange has and open and close portals
so that's kind of nice it looks like the
mcu is toying with this idea that ned
leeds might have some kind of magical
element to his character or something
like that you're not given nearly enough
to know what's going on all you know is
that he could just open portals and like
that's it right that's all that's all
you know there so it almost kind of
feels like a plot device if it wasn't
the mcu and you you didn't know they
were building up to something bigger but
basically like peter parker takes off
because one of the biggest things that
the movie happens aunt may dies right
and it's kind of crazy because when
she's killed by the green goblin she's
the one that gives peter parker the with
great power must also come great
responsibility speech because like he
hasn't gotten that yet so like he gets
it from her which is nuts but he
basically takes off and ned leeds and mj
don't know where he is so like literally
like ned lee uses his portal thing and
says i want to find peter parker and
then you see spider-man off in the
distance dude as soon as that portal
opened and you saw spider-man people in
the audience were just like oh my god
like everybody like you you know like
the feeling where like the audience was
like oh my god is it what i think it is
is it what i think it is and then like
spiderman comes running to the portal
and somebody was like please don't close
like somebody out there was like please
don't close and the portal light the
portal stays open and he jumps through
and you're just like oh my god okay so
like is it is is it is it not the same
costume as tom holland is it like is it
spider like like which spider-man is it
you know and like they immediately start
freaking out right like zendaya and uh
mj and and nedley like they start
freaking out they're like what the hell
is going on and like he takes off his
mask and it's andrew garfield dude the
top came off that movie theater when it
was andrew garfield people went nuts and
someone's just like they put him through
the paces they're like are you really
spider-man like crawl on the walls all
that kind of stuff show us you're really
spider-man so you get andrew garfield
and then they try again and they're like
okay let's try to find tom holland again
try to find you know our our friend
peter and so they open the portal and
it's toby mcguire who steps through this
time and so like i mean toby maguire
looks old right old man spider like he
looks old right he looks like an old guy
um but they're both in the movie now for
the first little while and what's really
really cool the way they handle this
you're not immediately off to the races
right it's not as though like andrew
garfield's there and toby maguire's
there and then like a minute and a half
later you know tom walks in the door
it's like just what i needed back up
cool let's go find the bad guys guys
we're like yeah mass on and like they
take off that's not what happens instead
is handled
incredibly well because you get this
this conversation between the three
right like like total mcguire asked the
question is there a place he goes to in
order to like kind of gain his bearings
right the place that grounds him that
makes him feel the most comfortable for
andrew garfield it was the empire state
building for toby mcguire it was the
chrysler building for tom it's the top
of midtown high school and so that's
where they go right mj and ned leeds
basically find him and they're like okay
there's a couple guys who want to talk
to you and like basically andrew
garfield and toby start talking to tom
holland and like tom's kind of pissed
doesn't want to hear anything right
because aunt may dies like you have no
idea what i'm going through that kind of
a thing and then andrew garfield's like
my girlfriend gwen stacy was killed and
toby's like my uncle ben died and that
kind of a thing and so like over time in
their conversation tom holland begins to
kind of cheer up a little bit and then
he was like well like like she told me
before she died with great power and
then toby finishes it must also come
great responsibility and then it's just
like yes
that's like they're brought together as
a team and then at that point it's
basically finding ways to cure the
villains of being villains and then turn
them back into normal humans and so you
get like some really really cool moments
which we'll actually cover in our easter
eggs video that we're releasing but you
get some really really cool moments with
the different characters some great
interactions it's phenomenal you have
this hilarious moment when like toby
mcguire uses organic webs and tom and
andrew were like what like we have to
make webs do you have any idea how many
times we've ran out of web fluid right
if only we had that it was just it's
stuff like that right um but the
interactions between the three are
phenomenal they're absolutely amazing
having said that all the stuff you guys
suspected in terms of like the big fight
at the end where you have like electro
and sandman and the lizard you're 100
right it is andrew garfield and toby
mcguire who are there alongside tom
holland right the scene where like where
we're basically like lizard gets punched
and his head flies to the side right in
the trailer but there was nobody there
that's andrew garfield right andrew
garfield is the one who hits him so you
guys basically nailed it in terms of at
least i'm pretty sure it's andrew
garfield but you guys are the ones who
nailed it with all that stuff right the
interactions are great um one of the
cool things and again we'll talk about
this in the easter egg videos is that
toby andrew and tom actually represent
the concept of spider-man in three
different eras right three different
aspects of his personality and things
that he's gone through but by and large
the movie was phenomenal i i loved it
it's one of the best movies now having
said that they basically reboot
spider-man because at the end of the
movie what basically ends up happening
is the green goblin gets his hands on
the box right which by the way
spider-man defeats doctor strange to get
that box with the spell that's held
inside right it's almost like the the
puzzle box from like hellraiser like
once doctor strange could you know
finishes the configuration and presses
the button on top they'll all go back to
their own universes so that'll basically
be it so that's kind of where the fight
would be on where the box comes from but
at the at the end of the movie in the
final battle green goblin gets the box
and then puts a pumpkin bomb in it and
basically like when they get it back
there's a pumpkin bomb inside the box
which explodes and the spell unleashes
right the spell goes nuts that's that's
the scene from the trailer when you see
like they're at the statue of liberty
which is getting captain america shield
which is awesome and like there's a huge
explosion right that's that right like
all the little cracks that you see where
a lot of rumors were saying it was like
kane the conqueror people like that it's
not what it actually is is it's
basically the spell reaching its full
conclusion where everyone across the
multiverse who knows that peter parker
is spider-man is starting to enter into
the universe specifically arriving on
earth so the only way to stop that is
for doctor strange to complete the spell
with no exceptions whatsoever because
that's what threw the spell awry is that
tom holland kept asking for exceptions
as the spell was being cast right so
doctor strange is like the whole world
will forget that peter parker is
spider-man he's like well what about ned
leeds what about aunt may what about you
know mj and so on and so forth and happy
needs to know and so on and that's what
made the spell go awry leading to all
this in the first place so at the end
tom holland is just like do the spell
make make everybody forget that i'm
spider-man i don't want anybody to know
that i'm spider-man like do it the way
it was supposed to be done and doctor
strange is like okay i love that moment
when doctor strange is like all of us
who love you will forget who you are
referring to himself as well and the
responsible peter is that's okay right
it's what needs to happen in order for
us to save all of reality otherwise
literally our universe will be filled to
the brim and god only knows what will
happen after that right so just wipe
this knowledge from everybody's minds
and that'll be it so like he says his
goodbyes to mj which is just this
amazing just this beautifully handled
scene it's absolutely gorgeous it's so
emotional and so impactful i felt like
it was more emotional than the death of
aunt may because a part of you kind of
knew that he might not do it right
because he told mj he's like i will come
and find you right like you know like
you are going to forget who i am but
it's okay i will come and find you and i
will tell you what's going on and i will
make you remember her she's like you
better right like you better make sure
that i remember and so so basically he
says his goodbyes and like the spell
goes through and everybody's mind gets
wiped about peter parker being
spider-man now this has also led to a
lot of questions that people have mariah
asked a really good question she's like
is this spell only on earth or is it
universe wide right like thor and the
guardians of the galaxy are out in space
have they forgotten that peter parker
spider-man or when they arrive back on
earth are they going to be like peter
how you doing man he's like nobody was
supposed to know that kind of a thing
what does this also do like how does it
affect like the digital sphere right
because when everybody knew the identity
of spider-man there were tweets and
there were there were social media posts
facebook or meta whatever they want to
call themselves but like in the digital
space all that stuff was out there they
didn't change time they just wiped
everybody's knowledge so are all those
tweets and all that digital information
is that all gone right the video
broadcast of j jonah jameson announcing
the identity of peter parker when
mysterio initially did it is all that
stuff out there now or did it somehow
get wiped those are questions we don't
have answers to that's never actually
answered in the movie at least not as
far as i'm aware it's something that i
may have missed but the thing about this
and what what made this so fantastic is
that peter parker basically ends up
sewing his own spider-man suit right so
he gets the classic like blue like royal
blue and red spider-man suit that like
you've always wanted to see him wear the
other thing is he finally catches up to
mj and ned leeds and then chooses not to
tell them he chooses not to inform them
of who he really is and just lets them
live their normal lives and so he
basically goes forward as like your
friendly neighborhood spider-man with no
one knowing who he is marvel rebooted
him so now they've got a clean slate
they can kind of go forward and
basically the whole origin story of
peter parker is everything that happened
from the time he first appeared in civil
war all the way up to this it's the
whole origin story of peter it's
phenomenal the way that it's done it's
handled beautifully
and then there's the post credits
remember the rumor that said that the
venom simulator a piece of the venom
symbiote was going to be left behind in
the marvel cinematic universe that
happens so the venom symbiote is now in
the mcu and that sets the stage for
marvel for the marvel cinematic universe
to create its own version of venom their
own version of eddie brock all that kind
of stuff to basically recraft the story
of peter parker as they see fit which
has you know callbacks presumably to
like infinity war in terms of peter's
remembrance of those things right maybe
revisiting a couple characters or like
checking up on happy hogan every once in
a while to see how he's doing but
basically no real bearings on anything
else outside of their ability to craft
their own story involving spider-man so
um that's gonna be really really
exciting the final post-credits scene
which we will actually do a video on is
the trailer for doctor strange two which
looks phenomenal oh my god it looks
absolutely amazing but all in all this
movie was great it was i mean tom
holland tom holland exercised a kind of
depth that i hadn't seen before that
i've been waiting on not to say he was
incapable of it but the writing of peter
parker in the marvel cinematic universe
simply didn't allow it that he was
basically the kid who was just kind of
growing figuring himself out and not
really taking superhero antics as
serious as they needed to be by the end
of this he becomes the peter parker you
always expected him to be right the
peter parker who cracks jokes because it
throws villains off off balance but he
doesn't crack jokes because he doesn't
take things seriously right he's very
serious he understands the full gravity
of what it means to do the kind of
things he's doing so the movie itself
was was absolutely great zendaya killed
it jacob babylon killed it the cast
absolutely nailed it what this means for
the future of their characters i don't
know they can bring back zendaya and
jacob battle on any time they want to
they're not dead they can bring them
back at any point in time whether or not
they choose to is a whole different
thing it can go either way it could just
be one of these things where peter's
like that's no longer a part of my life
and so ultimately because of that you
would you could potentially go forward
and never see or hear from mj or ned
leeds again i don't really think that'll
be the truth or be the case i think
we'll probably see them again at some
point in the future if they choose to
bring them back but it can kind of go
either way right they very much like
steve rogered these guys right just you
may or may not see them just kind of
depends on on on what it is that the
marvel cinematic universe wants to do so
having said that movie was phenomenal
best spider-man movie that was ever made
absolutely loved it um yeah it's it's
it's great you guys understand like go
and see it and then you will understand
my initial spoiler-free reaction where i
was just totally over the moon on how
great this movie was in terms of where i
would rank this movie i would put it in
my top three marvel cinematic universe
movies up to this point number one being
captain america in the winter soldier
number two being black panther and then
number three being this one yes i think
it's better than infinity war and
avengers in game in terms of like
overall events and like the the huge
impact of it all in terms of everything
that's happening no it's not on the same
scale as infinity war and avengers
in-game in terms of my personal
enjoyment of it yes i definitely liked
it better but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end thank
you guys for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace